Yes, it's that time of year
again, and for Numberphiles
that means one thing--
Advent calendars.
For each day of December, I'm
going to be adding a new video
link to each number
in the calendar.
On December 1, number
1; December 2,
number 2, and so on.
It could be a Numberphile
video, old or new.
It could be one of my other
videos from another channel or
from another YouTuber
altogether.
But the one thing they'll have
in common, either in an
obvious or nonobvious
way, is an
association with the number.
One of the videos is also going
to be an unlisted one
that you'll only be able to
watch through the Advent
calendar, because I'm a
bit sneaky like that.
I know that annotations don't
work for some people, so there
are also links under
the video.
So please, come back each day
of December, or whenever you
choose, and find out what
videos have been added.
And also, it's not too late to
suggest one, if there's one
you think I should
be linking to.
Well, if you're still here,
I'm going to tell you, you
should also be following
Numberphile on Twitter or
Facebook, links below.
All right, you've had
long enough now.
If you haven't clicked on
something by now, you're never
going to click, so I'm
stopping the video.